FEMALE VOICE: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Our lecture today concerns
mathematical induction, which,
roughly speaking, is a technique
that one uses to
prove something when one already
has a pretty good
suspicion as to what the
right answer is.
Now, rather than to philosophize
about this too
long, let's tear right into a
problem and see, in action,
just what the concept means.
Recall that, in an earlier
lecture, we have proven that
the limit of a sum is equal
to the sum of the limits
provided, of course, that
there are only two
terms in the sum.
That is, if we have two
functions, 'f 1' and 'f 2',
the limit of 'f1 of x' plus 'f2
of x' as 'x' approaches
'a' is the limit of 'f1 of x' as
'x' approaches 'a' plus the
limit of 'f2 of x' as
'x' approaches 'a'.
The question, now, is how
about the limit of 'x'
approaches 'a' of 'f1
of x', plus 'f2 of
x', plus 'f3 of x'?
Now, to tackle a problem like
this, we do what is so often
done in any mathematical
logical procedure.
We try to reduce an unfamiliar
problem to a familiar problem
which has already been solved.
Let's see what I mean by that.
If this had been only two
terms in here that we're
adding, we would have known how
to handle this problem.
So what we observe is that since
the sum of two functions
is, again, a function, we can
assume that our expression is
written this way.
Now, you see, we've reduced our
problem to the sum of two
functions, namely, 'f1 of x'
plus 'f2 of x' being one of
our functions, 'f3 of x' being
another of our functions.
We know, now, what?
That the limit of a sum is
the sum of the limits.
If we have two functions,
you see this is, what?
The limit 'f1 of x' plus 'f2 of
x', you see, plus the limit
as 'x' approaches
'a', 'f3 of x'.
But now, look what's in this
expression over here.
This is now, what?
The limit of the sum
of two functions.
And, you see, we know that the
limit of a sum is the sum of
the limits is true if we have
only two functions, so, from
here, we get to here.
And, from here, we
can say, what?
This is the limit 'x' approaches
'a', 'f1 of x',
plus the limit as 'x' approaches
'a', 'f2 of x',
'a', 'f3 of x'.
In other words, what we have
shown is that the limit of a
sum equals the sum of the limits
is true not just the
sum of two functions, but for
the sum of 3 as well.
And, more importantly, the truth
for 3 hinged directly on
the truth for 2.
In other words, it wasn't just
that we proved that the
formula was true for the sum of
three functions, we proved
it on the assumption that it was
already true for the sum
of two functions.
And, by the way, notice how we
may now begin to suspect that
this idea generalizes.
For example, let's take
a look over here.
Suppose I now said how
about the limit as
'x' approaches 'a'?
And we'll now take the sum of
four functions: 'f1 of x',
plus 'f2 of x', plus 'f3
of x', plus 'f4 of x'.
See, what about something
like that?
And, again, we argue the same
way as we did before.
We say, you know, if
we had only had two
functions in here--
and this gives us the
hint to do this--
see, we do know that the limit
of the sum is the sum of the
limits if we have only
two functions.
You see, now, I could
write this as, what?
It's the limit of the first one,
as 'x' approaches 'a',
but what is the first one?
The first one is the function
'f1 of x', plus 'f2 of x',
plus 'f3 of x', plus the
limit of the second.
The second now you see, is
'f sub four of x' as 'x'
approaches 'a'.
Now, you see our previous
case told us, what?
That the limit of a sum is equal
to the sum of the limits
if you have the sum of
three functions.
That's exactly what we have over
here, and now you see we
can say, what?
Ah, this is the limit of the
first as 'x' approaches 'a',
plus the limit of the second
as 'x' approaches 'a', plus
the limit of the third as 'x'
approaches 'a', plus the limit
the fourth as 'x'
approaches 'a'.
In other words, what
have we done now?
We've shown that knowing that
the limit of a sum is the sum
of the limits was true for a
sum of two functions and of
three functions.
We've shown, inescapably, that
the same result holds for the
sum of four functions.
Let's take a little breather
here and make a few asides.
I think, sometimes, when one
starts to work too much with
mathematical symbolism, we lose
track of the fact that
things are not quite as
difficult as they might
otherwise have seemed.
You see, for one thing, my claim
is that we have already
tackled this problem as recently
as first grade
arithmetic.
Namely, we learned, what?
We learned tables.
Remember the addition tables?
You learned how to
add two numbers.
All of a sudden somebody
says what is the sum of
1, 2, 3, and 4?
What is this number?
And what we said was, look
at, we'll just add
these two at a time.
1 plus 2 is a number,
which is 3.
3 plus 3 is a number,
namely 6.
And 6 plus 4 is a number: 10.
In other words, we essentially
did, what?
We added the first
to the second.
Then we added the sum of the
first two to the third, the
sum of the first three to
the fourth, and that
was how we did this.
Of course, what we assumed in
doing this was that the sum of
two numbers was, again,
a number.
Up above, we assumed
that the sum of two
functions was a function.
And this is not quite as trivial
as it might otherwise
have seemed.
Namely, look at, if you add two
odd numbers, do you get
like things when you combine
like things?
The sum of two odd numbers
is always even.
You see, you can't say let's
replace the sum of two odd
numbers by another odd number.
You can say it, but
it would be wrong.
On the other hand,
another example.
How about subtraction?
That's a nice operation.
If you subtract a positive
number from a positive number,
are you guaranteed that the
result will be positive?
Well, for example, what
about 3 less 5?
The answer would
be negative 2.
Positive minus positive can very
well be negative, so we
must be sure, what?
That, when we combine like
objects, we get like objects.
And another thing that we
assumed was that our answer
did not depend upon
voice inflection.
Now, what does that mean?
Let me show you something
over here.
Look at the expression 12
divided by 6 divided by 2.
If you read this as if it said
12 divided by 6 divided by 2,
the answer is 1.
On the other hand, if you read
the same thing as if it said
12 divided by 6 divided by
2, the answer is, what?
12 divided by 3, which is 4.
In other words, division depends
on voice inflection,
whereas, addition doesn't.
And I simply point out these
asides to show you that, as we
go through advanced mathematical
analysis, we are
always making use of the same
assumptions that we were
making when we dealt with
more simple things.
And I think this is the
healthiest way of seeing how
our subject develops.
We will leap from things that
we already know into
generalizations that are
less familiar to us.
At any rate, let's now return
to our main theme of
mathematical induction
and try to summarize
what's happened so far.
We are working with a certain
conjecture, let's call it.
The conjecture is that the limit
of the sum is the sum of
the limits.
We know that the conjecture
was true for two terms.
We proved that, once it was
true for two terms, it was
true for three terms.
We then prove that, if it was
true for three terms, it was
true for four terms.
And now, if we have any
imagination at all, we might
become suspicious and say, you
know, I think, if it's true,
in general, for 'n' terms,
it's going to be
true for 'n + 1' terms.
And that brings us to our next
stage in our mathematical
induction, namely, suppose the
limit of the sum is equal to
the sum of the limits in the
case that there are 'n' terms
in our sum.
What can we conclude about the
limit of a sum in the case of
'n + 1' terms?
And, without going through the
proof here, we'll do these
things in our supplementary
notes in our learning
exercises, but, here, I just
want to focus our attention on
what the main theme is.
What we say is, since we can
add without worrying about
voice inflection, why don't we
throw in a pair of braces
here, thus reducing our problem
to the limit of a sum
when we're adding but
two functions,
use the theorem there.
And, now, given the limit of the
sum of 'n' functions, we
know that that's the
limit of a sum.
And now, it appears that the
truth for 'n' is going to
imply the truth for 'n + 1'.
Now, of course, there may be
other problems that work
structurally this way other than
the limit of a sum equals
the sum of the limits.
So let's generalize
that result.
And the generalization
is what is known as
mathematical induction.
What mathematical induction says
is this, let's suppose we
have a conjecture.
Now, how we get the conjecture
is something we'll talk about
in a while, but let's suppose
we have the conjecture.
Well, to try to show that the
conjecture is true all the
time, we had better be sure it's
true at least sometimes.
So we say, OK, let's show that
the conjecture is true
for 'n' equals 1.
That's just a simple
verification.
We show that it's true
for 'n' equals 1.
Then we say OK, next, prove that
the truth for 'n' equals
'k' implies the truth for
'n' equals 'k + 1'.
In other words, we're not saying
that it's true for 'k',
all we're saying is that, if
it's true for 'k', if it's
true for 'k', the truth for
'n' equals 'k' implies the
truth for 'n' equals 'k + 1'.
Then, if that's true, our
conjecture is true for all
whole numbers.
Why is that?
Well, let's take a look,
informally, here.
Let's suppose that both of these
conditions are obeyed.
We know the conjecture is
true when 'n' equals 1.
Now, take 'k' to be 1.
Since it's true for 1, this part
tells us it's going to be
true for one more than
1, which is 2.
Now that the conjecture is true
for 2, this says, what?
It's going to be true for 3.
And knowing that it's true
for 3, this will say
it's true for 4.
And now I'll loosely use the
word et cetera, and come back
and reinforce that
as we go along.
I think now, perhaps, the best
thing to do is to look at a
second example.
You see, what we did first of
all was we used an example to
lead in to what the definition
would be.
Now that we have the definition,
let's proceed
directly to use it.
Let me give you a conjecture.
The conjecture which I have in
mind is that the sum of the
first n positive numbers--
and this is an interesting
formula--
it's the last number multiplied
by one more than
the last number divided by 2.
Well, let's just see if that's
true at all for a while.
Look at, if 'n' is 1, the
left-hand side here is 1.
And 1 times 2 divided
by 2 is also 1.
If 'n' is 2, the sum
of the first two
numbers here is, what?
One plus 2 is three.
On the other hand, 2 times
3 divided by 2 is also 3.
So, at least, our conjecture is
true for 'n' equals 1 and
'n' equals 2.
What does mathematical
induction say?
Let's take a look again, now.
You see, we showed that the
conjecture was true
for 'n' equals 1.
And, for good measure, we also
showed that it was true for
'n' equals 2.
So, we can check this off.
We've done that.
Now, what do we do?
We assume the conjecture is
true for 'n' equals 'k'.
That means, what?
Well, just replace 'n' by 'k'.
We're assuming that
this is true.
From the truth of this,
what must we do next?
Well, what we must do next is
investigate what happens if
you add, what?
Not 'k' numbers, but 'k + 1'.
So, in other words, what happens
when you replace 'n'
by 'k + 1'?
Now, watch how we do this.
The same thing that we did in
theory before, we say, look
at, we already know how
to handle this amount.
We're told that that's going to
be ''k' times 'k + 1' over
2', so let's rewrite
this in this way.
Now, we can replace the
bracketed expression by ''k'
times 'k + 1' over 2'.
We add on, of course, 'k + 1'
because that's the last term
that's over here.
Now, we factor out 'k + 1'
from this factor here.
That leaves us with, what?
'k/2 + 1'.
And this, in turn, says, what?
That the sum of the first 'k +
1' numbers is ''k + 1' times
'k + 2' over 2'.
And notice that that's exactly
what the conjecture should say
when 'n' equals 'k +
1', namely, what?
The sum of the first 'n'
numbers, no matter how many
you have, is, what?
The last number times one
more than the last
number divided by 2.
The sum of the first 'k
+ 1' numbers is, what?
It's 'k + 1', the last one,
times 'k + 2', which is one
more than the last one,
divided by 2.
And now, what we've done is we
have verified the second part
of our mathematical induction
setup, namely, if we go back
to our basic definition over
here, we have to show, what?
Prove that the truth for 'n'
equals 'k' implies the truth
for 'n' equals 'k + 1', which
is exactly what we did.
And, while you're thinking about
that, let's take a break
for a few more asides which, I
think, may cement down this
idea a little bit
more strongly.
I mentioned before that
induction is something that
one uses when one already has
a suspicion as to what the
right answer is.
I don't know how this grabs
you, buy my own particular
feeling is that you do not look
at the sum of the first
'n' numbers and say aha, it's
the last one times one more
than the last one
divided by 2.
You see, that's the nice thing
about textbook problems.
When they give you a problem
on induction and they say
prove this conjecture, notice
that they've already given you
a tremendous hint, namely,
they've told you what the
conjecture is.
You see, in the textbook of real
life, one usually has to
find out what the conjecture
is for oneself.
In fact, in the form of a rather
interesting aside,
there is a very interesting
mathematical anecdote
connected with this particular
problem.
It's an anecdote attributed to
the mathematician, Gauss, who,
when he was a young chap, was a
discipline problem in school.
And the story is that his
teacher, as a punishment,
asked him to add the
first 100 numbers.
And Gauss wrote down the answer
very, very rapidly.
And what he did was, he didn't
add these all up.
What he observed was, what?
The first one plus the last
one added up to 101.
The second plus the next
to the last added
up to 101, you see?
And each pair going in this
way added up to 101.
And how many pairs were
there, all together?
Well, there were 100 numbers,
so there were 50 pairs.
In other words, there
were, what?
100 divided by 2 pairs, each
pair adding up to 101.
And now, notice the recipe: 100,
namely the last number,
times one more than the last
number, 101, divided by 2.
By the way, in the exercises
on this assignment we have
another problem, and that is,
if you think this one was
already cumbersome, try guessing
what the recipe for
this one is: what is the sum
of the first n squares?
In other words, not 1, plus 2,
plus 3, et cetera, but 1
squared, plus 2 squared, plus
3 squared, et cetera.
I give you the answer, but try
to think for a while as to how
likely it is that you would have
conjectured this in the
first place.
It turns out to be ''n'
times 'n + 1' times
'2 n + 1' over 6'.
You see, the reason I bring this
out is that I call this a
contrived example.
It is not the case where the
mathematician would most
likely have invented
mathematical induction.
The case where he would have
invented mathematical
induction is the case that we
did earlier, for example,
where we talk about the
limit of a sum being
the sum of the limits.
You can actually see what's
happening, how the truth that
'k' implies the truth
for 'k + 1'.
And by the way, let me make
one more aside here that I
forgot to mention earlier.
In our definition of
mathematical induction, we
said show the conjecture is
true for 'n' equals 1.
This was quite hypocritical
because the very first example
that I picked didn't even
start until 'n' was 2.
We talked about the limit of
a sum being the sum of the
limits, and the smallest
sum we talked about was
the sum of two terms.
The point that I wanted to
mention is, for example,
suppose that the first number
you can prove the conjecture
for is, for example,
'n' equals 7.
I don't know why I picked 7.
I had to pick something.
Let's just call it
'n' equals 7.
Suppose I can also show that, if
the conjecture is true for
'k', it's true for 'k + 1'.
Then, you see, what I can
conclude is I can conclude
that it's true for 'n' greater
than or equal to 7.
Namely, if it's true for 7, this
says it will be true for
one more than 7, which is 8.
If it's true for 8, this says
it will be true for 9.
If it's true for 9, this
says it will be
true for 10, et cetera.
And we go on this way.
Now, again, this may be a very
naive way of looking at it,
but I always look at
mathematical induction as a
bunch of toy soldiers stacked
up in a line in such a way
that, if any one of the toy
soldiers falls down, he knocks
down the one that's immediately
behind him, OK?
You see what I'm driving
at here?
If the first falls-- and, by
the way, that's a big if--
if the first falls, he knocks
down the second.
The second falling knocks
down the third.
The third falling knocks
down the fourth.
The fourth falling down knocks
down the fifth, et cetera.
Notice that, if the first
one doesn't fall,
none of them fall.
Or, for that matter, going back
to my previous analogy,
if the seventh one is the first
one that falls, all the
ones behind him fall down.
Now, be very careful.
Mathematical induction doesn't
say the first 50 fall down, or
the first 100 fall down,
it says they all
have to fall down.
For example, here's a case where
several fall down, but,
all of a sudden, one isn't
knocked down by the one in
front of him.
In other words, what
mathematical induction really
involves is the idea not just
that something is true, but
that it's true because the
previous one was true.
You see, for example, is it
possible that all of the
soldiers fall down even though
the one in front didn't knock
the other guy down?
I mean, it's possible all of
these go down, but for
different reasons.
Mathematical induction says
much more than that.
yes, they all go down, but
each goes down because
of the one before.
And, by the way, one
more little aside.
Notice that, in our analog,
we assumed that
there was a next one.
You say, well, what do
you mean you assume
there was a next one?
Obviously, there has
to be a next one.
But, the concept of next depends
on whole numbers.
For example, when you
deal with fractions,
there is no next one.
Let me show you what
I mean by that.
Let's talk about the real
numbers in general.
On the number line, here's 0.
What is the first fraction,
the first real number?
I don't care what you call it.
What is the first number which
is greater than 0?
And the answer is, there
is none because
whichever one you pick--
call it 'r'.
Let 'r' stand for the first
number which you think is
bigger than 0, OK?
How about 'r/2'?
'r/2' is still bigger than 0,
but 'r/2' is less than 'r'.
In other words, given any number
you pick that's bigger
than 0, you can fit
in another one.
So, there is no number which
is immediately next to 0.
In other words, as a caution,
notice that mathematical
induction is used when
we're dealing with a
whole number of objects.
Now, let's emphasize some of
these little asides from a
more specific point of view.
Let me, first of all, give you
an example in which something
is true for a whole bunch of
numbers, but, all of a sudden,
isn't true in general.
Now, how anybody ever stumbled
across the example I'm going
to give you next, I have no
idea, but I find it's a very
interesting concept.
Let's look at this.
Let's write down the following
function: 'p' of 'n', where
'n' is any positive whole
number, will be defined to be
'n' squared, minus
'n', plus 41.
For example, 'p' of 1 will be
1 squared, minus 1, plus 41,
which happens to be 41.
41 happens to be a prime number:
a number which has no
factors other than
itself and 1.
Let's try 2 in here.
2 squared, minus 2, plus 41,
is 43: also a prime number.
Let's try 3 in here.
3 squared is 9, minus 3
is 6, plus 41 is 47:
also a prime number.
The amazing thing is that, as
you go all the way through to
40, you get nothing
but prime numbers.
And you say, ah, it's right
so far, it must be
right all the time.
And this is wishful thinking.
This is like the man who wants
to count the deck of cards to
see if the cards are all there,
and he says one, two,
three, four, five.
Well, so far, so good.
They must all be here.
It's like falling off the Empire
State building, and
halfway down, somebody says,
"How you doing?" You say, "So
far, so good." No, we're in a
little bit of trouble here
because, as soon as we pick
'n' to be 41, watch what
happens here.
This becomes 41 squared,
minus 41, plus 41.
And this is 41 squared, which,
obviously, is not a prime.
It's 41 times 41.
And here is an interesting
example where a certain
formula generates nothing but
primes for the first 40
integers, but fails on
the 41st integer.
Why did this happen?
Because, evidently, the fact
that this was a prime in no
way depended structurally
on the fact that
this one was a prime.
There is our mathematical
induction again, that not only
must the conjecture be true, but
it must follow inescapably
from the case before.
If you'd like a more
fascinating, realistic
example, it's something that
we call the unique
factorization theorem of
elementary number theory.
This says that every positive
whole number greater than one
can be factored uniquely into a
product of primes, unique up
to the order in which
you write them.
For example, 2 is already
a prime, it's 2.
3 is already a prime: 3.
4 can be factored
as 2 times 2.
5 can be factored as--
well, it's already
a prime, it's 5.
6 can be written as, what?
2 times 3.
7 can be written,
of course, as 7.
It's already a prime.
8 is 2 times 2 times 2.
9 is 3 times 3.
10 is 2 times 5, and 11
is already a prime.
Well, this doesn't
prove anything.
I'm just trying to demonstrate
what the theorem says.
The interesting thing is do you
notice how 'n + 1' factors--
I don't know what phrase to use
here, but let's call it
considerably different
than 'n'.
In other words, look at what
happened to 10 when I
added 1 onto it.
It factored into 2 times 5.
I add 1 onto it, and, all of
a sudden, the factorization
properties change.
Let me give you an example.
Look at 59.
59 happens to be a prime.
Look at 61.
61 also happens to be a prime.
By the way, for those of you are
number theory buffs, these
are called twin primes.
Consecutive odd numbers, which
are both prime, are called
twin primes.
By the way, 2 is the only even
prime, of course, because, if
a number is greater than
2, and it's even, it's
divisible by 2.
So, 2 is the only even prime.
Twin primes are, what?
Consecutive odd numbers both
of which are primes.
So, 59 and 61 are a pair
of twin primes.
One might intuitively suspect,
therefore, that the number
between them must be sort
of a prime too, or
whatever that means.
Obviously, it can't be a prime
because in between them comes
60, which is, in particular,
an even number.
But look at all the nice
factors that sixty has.
60 is, what?
It's one more than 59, one less
than 61, but look at how
different it factors.
In fact, a pseudo induction-type
thing is look
at the factors of 60:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
We say, what?
7, experimental error?
No, no.
But, this is not induction,
by the way.
The fact that 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
and 6 are all factors of 60
does not mean that 7 is going
to be a factor of 60.
We do not say just because it
works so far, it's going to
keep working.
And I'm not going to belabor
this point anymore.
Suffice it to say that look at
how differently 60 factors
compare to the number the came
just before it and the number
that came just after it.
In other words, assuming that
the unique factorization
theorem is true, the truth for
'n + 1', somehow or other, has
nothing to do with the
truth for 'n'.
And you see this is, again,
another weakness of, what's
called, induction.
Well, so, that's a weakness
of induction.
The point that I'm making is why
shouldn't induction have
some weaknesses?
After all, if it could solve
every problem, what we would
do is have a calculus book that
was three pages long.
It would be called,
The Principle of
Mathematical Induction.
When we solved that problem by
induction, everything else
would be done.
No, there are problems
that do not lend
themselves to induction.
In summary, induction is a
particularly effective
technique which one uses to
prove that something is true
for all whole numbers provided
that one has a suspicion that
this thing is true in
the first place.
And secondly that, even if the
suspicion is true, the truth
for the 'n' plus first case
follows inescapably from the
truth for the n-th case.
At any rate, this completes
our lecture for today.
And, until next time,
good bye.
MALE VOICE: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.